un petit matin frisquet de février
quelque part dans la campagne comtoise
une ferme ou créer une mare
et des animaux
cette image familière ce monde des
merveilles pour petits enfants des
villes cache un véritable théâtre
miniature du monde animal
les canards les poules et les oies de la
basse-cour rob est encore largement aux
instincts ils sont hérités de leurs
ancêtres sauvage
à
difficile d'imaginer la basse-cour comme
une jungle où une brousse
pourtant les hommes ont peu à peu
organiser la vie de certaines espèces en
fonction de leurs propres besoins en
nourriture
puis cela ne remonte qu'à quelques
siècles autrement dit presque rien à
l'échelle de l'histoire naturelle
comme leurs cousins qui vivent
aujourd'hui à l'état sauvage dans
d'autres contrées les animaux dits
domestiques se reproduise défendent leur
territoire et élèvent leurs petits
les ancêtres de notre la fin d'année en
liberté dans des garennes surveiller
certes mais qui n'avait rien à voir avec
les clapiers moderne il ya à peine 150
ans que les cages à lapins ont résolu
leur crise du logement
avant de devenir célèbre dans le domaine
architectural
le dindon ramener d'amérique du sud par
les conquérants espagnols du xvième
siècle et est un mets de choix par le
gourmet de la renaissance
le ce matin c'est avec moins de
raffinement que de mal manifestent leur
rivalité
combat s'est terminé par la mort d'un
des adversaires
dans le petit monde de la basse-cour
l'autorité des oies s'applique même aux
mystères de la mort qui frappe les
autres animaux
m
et
imagine-t-on une basse-cour sans coqs
poules et poulets
comme leurs cousines sauvage du forez
indienne les boules parcours la prairie
en quête de vers de terre et d'insectes
j'ajoute des petits cailloux qui est
drôle en puissance gésiers à broyer la
nourriture
la bonne
les canards de barbarie eux aussi
apprécient les prairies et les des
nichons cas sauvage qui filtre du bec
et hiérarchie entre dominants et dominés
organise la société annales
quand il s'agit d'être le chef du groupe
destin des da don est tout tracé se
battre ou se soumettre
vaincre ou fuir
doucement menaçant s'ajoutaient signe de
colère sous la tête du dindon les
excroissances de chair rouge appelée car
se gonfle des clubs mal s'apprête
à la bataille
la tête plaie du da don est dure comme
un casque qui le protège des coups de
bec du rival c'est l'endurance et
l'acharnement qui font la différence
les oies et les jarres sont les seniors
redouter de ce royaume miniature
à l'état sauvage lejard vit en couple la
vie domestique l'a fait passer à la
polygamie
ses amours sont toujours aquatique tuto
bord d'un plan d'eau qu'il montre son
point commun avec les canards c'est un
des rares oiseaux doté d'un pénis
oh
l'hiver est enfin finie dans toute la
basse-cour le printemps et signe d'air
de tendre et d'humeur amoureuse
c'est la lapine qui donne le signal
quand le mal reprend son rôle il tape du
pied mais pas par et patience c'est un
très ancien signal d'alarmé du temps des
terriers
privé de son abri improvisé
l'orvet choisit d'abord une discrète
immobilité qui ne suffit pourtant pas à
tromper la vue perçante des poules
deuxième astuces n'échappe à ces
attaques en se séparant ça que grâce à
une fort commode vertèbres très
tranchant
voilà qui est mérité le surnom de
serpent de mer
tandis qu'un couple de pigeons se
manifeste sa fidélité le canard lui
aussi passé à la polygamie s'accommode
péniblement de la terre ferme à part ses
amours compliquées
c'est dans l'eau qu'il est le plus à
l'aise
du moins en principe
on poulailler rennes la plus stricte de
hiérarchie toute nouvelle arrivante doit
étudier son installation avec la plus
grande prudence
dans les confortables niche où le
fermier a placé deux fois en deux ans
pierre pour attirer ses pensionnaires
les poules vont couvent et une dizaine
de
l les retourne régulièrement un
manoeuvre pour but d'empêcher les jaunes
de coller à la coquille les jaunes ce
sont les embryons des futurs pousseur
les poules pondent en moyenne plus d'une
centaine deux parents
d'autant plus si elles améliorent leur
ordinaire avec les produits de la chasse
la poule couveuse sait d'instinct que
les deux doivent pas refroidir pour que
l'embryon deviennent pousse à l'issue
des trois semaines de couvaison elle
déteste être dérangé
pendant que les couveuses montent la
garde
le coq visite ponctuellement ses trois
ou quatre autres femelles il transmettra
aux poulettes de sa descendance les
qualités de sa propre mère
loi de guinée dont l'élégance évoque le
signe est la descendante des oies
sauvages d'afrique que l'homme a appris
à domestiquer
exigeante sur le logement elle prend
soin elle aussi de retourner chez eux
elle va couvé pendant un mois
notre coq gaulois doit sa fière allure à
son ancêtre asiatiques le coq sauvage de
banque il ya plus de 5000 ans que les
hommes apprécient son chant puissant et
son plumage chatoyant on séduire sa
partenaire il lui offre une petite
démonstration de danse
en
oh
mais le cop domine en supporte mal les
amours des autres
toute victoire est relative loi ne perd
jamais une occasion de rappeler que
c'est elle qui commande
je
e
et
à
pardon
ce n'est pas parce qu'on trouve qu'on a
la paix
ynwa grise vient revendiquer sans
ménagement le lit douillet de loi de
guinée
le genre de guinée s'ils y allant
soufflant avec colère qui vient prendre
sa part de la couvaison
le nid patiemment aménagé à l'abri des
intempéries est soumis à forte
concurrence
ni d'un d'insolente n'hésite pas à jouer
les coupes
décidément rude journée pour les oies de
guinée
alors que les dogues savent se contenter
de quelques brindilles dans les buissons
les pigeons portant plus sauvage
apprécient le confort du pigeon
ses locataires très possessif supporte
mal d'être envahi par des fâcheuses
le pigeon est frappé de stupeur avoir
tant d'audace et une poulette sans
compter qu'un nouvel intrus se présente
china team version ne suffit pas le
score des coups de bec reçues et donner
des sites provisoirement d'un ordre
hiérarchique qui rétablit le
propriétaire dans ses droits
un mois passé les averses de printemps
se font rares
tout est calme dans le poulailler où une
oie s'est réfugié ces oiseaux vont être
séché avant de s'enduire de gras au
contact des sécrétions précieuse produit
par la mer
c'est le secret d'une bonne
imperméabilité à l'eau qui permettra aux
oiseaux de suivre leur mère sur la mare
voilà ce qui arrive quand on couvent à
l'écart la renarde n'a pas hésité à
visiter le poulailler en plein jour
elle aussi a des petits à nourrir
des oiseaux grandissent très vite au
bout d'une semaine ils peuvent courir
sur l'herbe et s'essayer à d'autres
nourritures que labatt est préparée par
le fermier
les rayons du soleil printanier font le
bonheur des pintades de leurs origines
africaines elles ont gardé le besoin de
chaleur créative et sauvage et se
perchent la nuit dans les arbres pour
s'abriter des prédateurs le jour elles
vivent en groupe sans trop se mêler aux
autres animaux
la dette une couveuse si dévouée qu'elle
peut en oublier de manger de boire
elle veille jalousement sur sa
progéniture
les dindonneau son malhabile et créatif
non pas un prix à chercher leur salut
dans la fuite et sont sûrs de pouvoir
compter sur le tempérament irritable de
leur mère pour écarter les importuns
dans le nid de pie ix de poils que la
lapine à confectionner et la promesse
tenue mais pour pierre sous des
sans-défense
leur mère les à l'etrat et veillera sur
eux pendant près de cinq semaines
avec le retour du printemps
la bergeronnette qui a élu domicile sous
le toit est elle aussi devenue chargée
de famille
après plus d'un mois de couvaison c'est
au tour des canetons de barbarie de
sortir de l'ue
comme les autres oiseaux qui passent la
première semaine très de leur mère dans
un calme parfois relatif
l'été s'installe il est temps pour les
oiseaux et les canetons d'aborder leur
carrière de la jambe
sur l'eau comme à terre ces lois le chef
et elle tient à le rappeler
cette fois c'est la can qu'il va falloir
mettront pas
oh
quand on est un petit canard et qu'on
imite bien ses parents on apprend vite à
plonger à nager à se sécher et
imperméabilisées soi même ses plumes les
canetons dispose désormais de leurs
propres réserves de graisse
le couple des pigeons c'est relayé pour
couver ils y arrivent pourtant
d'abandonner lui ni
les pigeonneaux se retrouve privé de
l'est de pigeons cette sorte de gelée
royale que les parents régurgite du
jabot et sans laquelle ils ne peuvent
survivre
les poule couveuse ont patienté trois
semaines avant d'entendre le premier
craquement le poussin attaque sa copie
par des poussées en arrière de la tête
et du bec
le premier trou percé par le pousse à sa
peine le ping lui donne accès à la poche
d'air de l'oeuf ou il peut remplir ces
petits poumons pour tes pieds
énergiquement
le pousse à découper un peu un capuchon
pour ensuite briser complètement sa
coquille
une demi journée à peine suffira aux
poussins pour être fin prêt à explorer
la prairie dès qu'ils auront séché leurs
duvets à la chaleur du pin âge maternel
chez les canetons la curiosité l'emporté
parfois sur la prudence nous ignorent
encore que le jard veille à ses
prérogatives et qu'on risque gros à le
défier
à peine les oeufs sont il est clos qu
une nouvelle rivalité se déclare pas
fabriqué à neuf il faut beaucoup de
passion
chaque poule produit en une année plus
da kg de coquilles et les coquilles
c'est du calcium alors rien ne se perd
tout se recycle et la concurrence fait
rage
un dangereux prédateur ce hérisson
pas vraiment mais en tout cas un grand
amateur de frais
trop tard les dindes l'ont vu
se mettre en boule ne suffit pas à
calmer ces dames il va falloir affronter
un élément nettement moins familiers
les petits lapins grandissent dans
quelques mois ils contribueront à leur
tour à la crise du logement
le soleil de juillet et d'herbes de la
prairie ainsi talent aventure et le
monde est bien trop vaste pour un si
petit poussin
ne donne lui aussi se sent d'humeur
aventureuse
il avoue se prendre pour un canard sa
mère est c'est que son plumage n'est pas
atteignable à l'eau
mais elle n'a pas oublié qu'elle est un
gros oiseau et qu'elle sait très bien
volé surtout quand ces petits sont en
danger
quelques semaines à peine après la fin
de la couvaison les dindons sont à
nouveau prêts à s'accoupler
quand revient la période des amours le
plumage du dindon se fait brillant
chatoyant et bariolés
hackers l'éventail les plumes gonfler la
lueur majestueuse le prétendant se
propose mais ce n'est pas au plus beau
que la femelle accorde ses faveurs c'est
ton plus fort
fait désormais très chaud
tronche
époux se retrouve au coi poudrier rien
ne vaut un bon bain de poussière pour
chasser les parasites et se débarrasser
d'agrès s'accumuler sur le cul
on
vim
tous les animaux cherchent l'ombre la
chaleur accablante incite à la sieste
à la sieste ou au bain pour leur
toilette de canard préfère me
l'entretien du plumage est l'occasion le
jeu aquatique débridé pour les petits
comme pour les ceintures
chaleur a eu raison des meilleures
énergies
dans le poulailler la torpeur gagne
les poules suffoque
faute de glandes sudoripares pour
évacuer l'eau l écarter plume une grand
le bec et respire à rythme accéléré
ah ah
leur âge apporte avec lui une fraîcheur
bienvenue et la délicieuse surprise
les animaux de la basse-cour reprennent
leur chasse leur jeu et leur bagarre
au contact parfois brutales des adultes
les jeunes apprennent peu à peu les lois
de leur petit royaume
caneton et oiseaux auront bientôt l'âge
des amours ils ont connaîtront les jeux
et les rivalités
et poussa apprendront à reconnaître les
friandises qui composeront leur menu
sauvage
mais avant tout les jeunes devront se
faire une place dans le groupe et la
défendre
comme leurs parents avant te ils
s'intégreront à la hiérarchie qui régit
la basse-cour et de saison en saison ils
seront guidés par les instincts du monde
sauvage dont ils sont les descendants
sous le contrôle taux longs
et